this is question 2 in the set that I
gave you which I did not assign you to
do but as some of you have noticed this
Patrick doesn't always make his
questions be all in difficulty he's just
like I'm just going to give you a hard
one second question up so hopefully by
the time I'm done this and finished with
any ice not so hard but there are some
curveballs in it so let me read the
question between our lamp is 6 meters
directly above aspect heart 6 meters
okay man 2 meters tall oh by the way I
don't know how much attention you pay to
numbers but you're like really so
basically this is Michael Jordan
actually Michael Jones only 1.98 meters
tall copy I make these where he's cream
torn away does that mean a song okay so
yeah I teach brain medicine is tall
Michael Jordan walks along the path I
suppose I should put two meters there he
walks along the path away from one light
and a constant speed of one meter per
second so it's going that way
second now what speed is the end of this
shadow groove along the path at what
speed is the length of the shadow
increasing okay so two questions let's
take it one more time firstly and what
speeds the end of his shadow move me
along the path okay so I guess we should
probably put um the shadow on there
right so where is the end of his shadow
it corresponds to the top of the line
going towards the top of his head so
something like this okay so I guess the
end of a shadow would like here so if I
drew a shadow in there's Mike Rotolo
shutter okay so I want to know uh sorry
what is it going to say what speed is
the end of
shadow moving along the path the end of
his shadow okay so in other words he's
moving but his shadow is growing okay
because you can imagine if you stood
right here directly underneath the land
right if that was possible his shadow
would be directly underneath him so his
shadow wouldn't have any length right
but it's getting longer the further he
gets it was away for the left which is
why at the end of the day towards sunset
your shadows really well so I want to
know how quickly this is moving and it's
going that direction okay so to start I
need to put on some variables here so
that I can know what's going on all
right so for instance I know I've been
given this one meter per second okay so
that's the distance that he's moving
away namely this distance in here okay
so I need to give this distance the name
so I'm just going to call this X meters
okay by the way you can call these
anything you like obviously it's in your
interest to try and choose something
which is memorable that makes sense but
it doesn't matter then secondly what am
I actually after okay I'm after this
shadow at this end movie okay so that's
this whole distance from here to here
okay so if I put that in it's that
distance that's the total that's the end
of shadow that's where it's going to be
so since it's about as shallow
we can call it yes okay so we've been
given which quantity here X which is
increasing that's happy yeah so that's
going to be DX on the team because its
length time yes that's just 1 and what I
want to find is the whole thing right
how's it s changing
I'll tell you at the end of the shadow
is doing so I want des on DT okay so
I've been one of your hair so far but
you tell me what do i what am I going to
do at this point
I'm gonna think of what different rates
are related to each other related rates
so channel so I want des want something
times something on DT okay and the other
variable we got is ABS right so the XO
DT so I can actually by the way it just
in this case right because DX of U T is
just one I can sort of just ignore this
guy because this so the question really
is what is des clumsy yet I need some
kind of relationship between s and X
okay now you've seen figures like this
before what a relationship work
geometric properties are by looking at
which will relate X there are similar
triangles here right so maybe if I draw
it without all the extra fluff on it
might be a little obvious if I draw it
like this
I've got a 6-meter lamp and Michael
Jordan who's two meters right and then I
have X in here okay and I've got s here
so what would be the relationship
between these two well you'd say by
similar triangles hmm hold on a second
you have to be careful here I can match
up the two the seats that's okay
that'll be one part of it but which
science do they correspond to the seeks
corresponds to the beach side which is s
so be something fun is but what's the
shortest side I'll give you a tip it's
not X because X is not a sign in a
triangle what is the sidewalk s - next
okay little things over Tiffany so s X
so now I can simplify a little bit this
is one over three
okay
cross multiply gives me s 3x now at this
point just I could simplify in different
directions
I don't want DS over DX right so what
should I make this object s right so
let's see what do that okay alright so
now that I have this is the subject I
can work out what DS on DX is
differentiate with respect to X and
that's just okay so now I come back to
my chain rule and I can fill in the gaps
now this is 3 over 2 1 and 1/2 times 1
so the actual change in s for the time
is 1.5 meters per second okay the shadow
is is sorry the end of the shadow that's
what I'm interested is moving at that
rate
okay so I have two questions that's the
first one all right
I think the trickiest thing was just
making sure you setup the right very
rules I mean for instance for me when I
first look at this question my
instinctive thing is I should be trying
to work out something to do with the
length of the shadow right and sure
enough you can work that out but you can
see by it the kinds of numbers you've
got you're trying to like s and X plus L
and X the numbers come out really easily
pick the right ones all right now the
second part of the question was at what
speed is the length of his shattered
increasing at what speed is the length
of his shadow increased so it's getting
longer right now we said back from my
civil triangles liner right but the
length of the shadow is is s minus ax
right meters so I want to know how that
thing is changing over time okay so this
is my--this missing so I'm trying to
work out how is s minus X that thing
changing as time changes okay
now you might look at that big moon what
I do in this thing how are whack with it
it's easier than it looks and let me
give you an example to try and draw that
out okay if I said to you can you please
differentiate x squared minus X okay
most of you are not thinking about it
really because you're circuited now but
you're treating these two things is
quite separate if you differentiate one
and then you differentiate the other
right so really what your brain is doing
is differentiate the first one and then
differentiate the second one then you
get your 2x minus 1 right well I can do
exactly the same thing here I can
differentiate the first one which is s
and then I differentiate the second one
which is X see my X helpful cuz I know
exactly what DSR the changes and I know
what DX on these tears well because the
question gave it to me ts on DT is 1.5
that's what we worked
here right and the excellent tea is just
one so like I'm thinking just about the
shadow itself it's growing it's getting
along better rate of poppers okay wasn't
so hot but again it's it's not hard once
you've been trained how to do it the
tricky parts off of the setup yeah and
then knowing look I can just treat these
as two separate things
this is the UM detail s Aditya